[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God.
All right. You can call me. Yes. I
wanted your thoughts on uh on 1094. Um
what what do you think of the verse and
its interpretation? What is the verse?
Uh where it talks about how if Muhammad
is in doubt to go and ask the people of
the scripture. Doubt about what? The
Quran. It says, "If you are in doubt
about that which we have revealed to
you, then go and ask those who have been
reading the scripture before you. Truly,
the truth has come to you from your
Lord. So, be not of those who doubt."
What's it referring to? Referring to the
Quran. Why do you believe it's referring
to the Quran? Because that's what was
revealed to Muhammad. No, not
necessarily. How is it understood? So,
by our classical scholars, how is that
understood? That verse. Well, so yeah.
So, it's understood that it's talking
about the Quran. What was revealed to
Muhammad? the Quran and and the prophecy
about read the verse. Read the verse.
Read the I did and maybe read a few
verses before it. Okay. Okay. So, if you
if you read the story, let's I mean, if
you read if you read the surah and
understand what it's about, it's telling
about all the prophets of the past and
and their miracles and such. Yeah. And
talking about what happened to Pharaoh
and all of these things. Yeah. Yeah. And
then at the end it says, "If you're in
doubt about what we've revealed to you,
referring to these stories." Yeah. So
basically Allah is is telling Muhammad
about um stories of the past about all
the things maybe Jonah and the whale
because this is called Jonah. Um the
idea that you know a giant fish
swallowed him and he was alive and he
came out the idea of seas parting the 10
plagues of Egypt. this type of stuff.
Yeah. Because this is this is an Arabia
pagan area. Maybe not know the stories
or of the the narrative of the prophets
prior to uh Muhammad's prophethhood. So,
so Allah is revealing these stories,
reminders to him. And then Allah says,
if you think these stories are like
too fantastical, Yeah. ask those who
were reading the scripture before you.
Yeah.
um as to these things. But it's not
saying ask those people is the Quran
true. That's not how it's understood.
Okay. Or how I understand it or I don't
think anyone understands it apart from
you. Okay. So um I would say yeah that
it's it does definitely include the
stories that mentions prior to the
verse. That's that's pretty consistent.
Um I would also say that it includes the
descriptions of Muhammad that's supposed
to be in their scriptures. That's what
like uh quite a few scholars say like I
and alabar and court. It doesn't mention
that. It doesn't mention anything about
this justifying Muhammad's prophethood.
None of it is. So what would you say?
It's just saying it's just saying first
thing is the caveat. If you have doubts,
right? Not you have doubts. If you if
you're thinking that this is something
um go speak to those people who read the
scriptures before you. And like I say
and I think you've heard this said there
were Muslims who used to be Jews and
Christians um who could be asked have
you heard of these stories type thing.
So but there's nowhere in this surah is
it mentioning to test the prophethhood
of Muhammad? I don't believe let me just
see. So would you so then you would
disagree with that position that I holds
that this includes the prophethood of
Muhammad like him being mentioned in the
scriptures? Yeah let me let me let's see
let's see these are the Alamra. These
are the verses of the wise book. Is it a
wonder to the people that we inspired a
man from among them, warned mankind, and
given news to those who believe that
they are on a sound footing with their
Lord? Okay. So, this is talking about
Muhammad. Yeah. The disbeliever said,
"This is a manifest sorcery. Your Lord
is God who created the heavens and the
earth in six days and settled on the
throne." Okay. To him is your return.
Altogether, the promise of God is true.
He originates creation. Then he repeats
it to reward those who believe and do
good deeds with equity. As for those of
disbelief, for them is a drink of
boiling water, agonizing torment on
account of their disbelief. It is he who
has made the sun radiant and the moon
and the light determine phases for it
that you may know in the alteration
night and day and in what God created in
the Those who don't know hope to meet us
and are contempt with the worldly life
and are at ease at it. Then those are
the pain no key to our signs. These
their dwelling is the fire on account of
what they used to do. As for those who
believe and do good deeds, their Lord
guides them in their faith. Rivers will
flow beneath them in the gardens of
bliss. Their call therein is glory be to
you our God and their greeting therein
is peace and the last of their call is
praise be to God lord of the worlds. If
God was to accelerate the ill for the
people as they wish to accelerate the
good their term would have been
fulfilled. But we leave there those who
do not expect our encounter to blunder
in their excesses. Whenever adversity
touches the human being he prays to us
reclining on his side or sitting or
standing. But when we revealed his
adversity from him, relieved his
adversity from him, he goes away as
though we had never called on us for
trouble that had afflicted him. Thus the
deeds of the transgressors appear good
to them. We destroy generations before
you when they did wrong. Their
messengers came to them with clear
signs, but they would not believe. Thus
we requite the sinful people. Then we
made the successors on earth after them
to see how you would be behave. And when
our clear revelations are recited to
them, those who do not hope to meet us
say, "Bring a Quran other than this or
change it." say, "It is not for me to
change it of my own accord. I only
follow what is revealed to me. I fear I
have disobeyed my lord, the torment of a
terrible day." Sorry, I know I'm reading
it all, but I don't want to get full
comments. Today, we will preserve your
body so that you may become a sign for
those after you, but most people are
heedless of our signs. And we settled
the children of Israel in a position of
honor and provided them with good
things. They did not differ until
knowledge came to them. Your Lord will
judge between them on the day of
resurrection, regarding their
differences. If you're in doubt about
what we reveal to you, ask those who
read the scripture before you. The truth
has come to you from your Lord. So do
not be of those who doubt. And do not be
of those who deny God's revelations,
lest you become one of the losers. Those
against whom your Lord's word is
justified will not believe. Even if
every sign comes to them until they see
the painful punishment. Okay. So yeah,
it's clearly um telling the stories of
the prophets talking from Noah through
to Moses um and telling how you know
they were saved from Pharaoh and all of
these things. And the people who would
know that is those who were reading the
scripture before. So that you asked my
you asked the question how do I
understand it? That's how I understood
it. Okay. And and I think that's a fair
understanding. Sorry I had to read all
that but I just wanted to familiarize
yourself with it. No, no, it's it's
good. It's good. So yeah, I would say
that your understanding is a is a fair
one. I would say that um like because
when I when I read Ibek and a few others
they include like they they acknowledge
that that it's you know about the
stories of previous prophets how the
Quran confirms these things and then
also how Muhammad's descriptions are in
these um are are in the previous
scriptures and he can he can see and
check like they they bring up an example
with a guy named Abdullahbin Salam who I
guess converted to Islam. He was a Jew
converted. Um, Muhammad asked him, "Am I
in your scriptures?" And he said, "Yes."
And quoted, you know, talked about the
scripture he was mentioned in. So, okay.
Thank you. I've not read the I'm not
read the and the hadith and the
reliability of such hadith. Okay. All
right. Yeah. Well, I think your
interpretation is a fair one. Let let me
ask you this because um I I run this
argument using this verse saying that I
I believe that this verse demonstrates
that the previous scriptures are an
authority over the Quran. And let me
even if I'm being gracious, let's say
concerning the stories that it's talking
about, right? Let's concerning the
things that it mentioned to Muhammad
that the Quran points to the previous
scriptures as an authority. In case he's
in case he's doubting what the Quran
says about them, he can go and check the
previous scriptures or ask those who
read scripture. Doesn't say that. It
says those who are reading it, right?
And so obviously it doesn't say go read
the scripture, does it? No. No. It says
go ask those who are reading the
scripture because They'll read the
scripture to him, right? They'll tell
him what the scripture says. Well, no,
no, they didn't say that either, does
it? But continue. Well, I I think that's
I think that that's the conclusion, the
logical conclusion like
Well, so so I don't believe I I
personally don't believe he had to ask
anybody anything because there's no
reason not to believe what Allah told
him. Sure. Yeah. Sorry. Say no. Yeah.
Yeah. I I I can grant that. I'm just
saying because Allah gives a condition,
right? It's a if. It's a hypothetical.
you know if this then this right and so
he says yeah of course of course if
you're in doubt about these stories ask
those who are reading like we said the
Muslims who used to be Jews and
Christians right okay so so the point in
no way shape or form is that a
confirmation oh the Quran is true well
well it is
can I ask you a question
I I was can I say what I was about to
say first and then yeah go on okay so
I'm I'm saying when Allah gives this
hypothetical Right? If you're in doubt,
then go and ask those who've been
reading the scripture before you. Right?
This Allah points to the previous
scriptures as the verifier of the Quran
because the whole point is if you're
doubting, this is how you can clear up
your doubts about what what has been
revealed to you.
You know, if if you're doubting, this is
what you can do to clear up any doubts
that you might have about what's been
revealed to you by using the previous
scriptures. So if Muhammad goes and asks
those who've been reading the scripture
and they and he sees that, okay, what
he's what's been revealed to him lines
up with what they have, then he'll know
that the Quran is true and have no
reason to doubt. Yeah, you could say
that. And then that means the opposite
is true that if he goes and asks them
and he sees that the Quran's not in
line, then he'll have good reason to
doubt and see that he's not. Okay,
that's fair. So, so my conclusion is is
that that demonstrates that the previous
scriptures at least in this case is the
authority over the Quran regarding these
previous You keep saying why is it I
would say I would use the term authority
because it's it determines if the Quran
is true or not regarding these stories.
I wouldn't say it's the authority. I
wouldn't say it's the validation as
such. Why? Why not? Tell me why not. U
because like I say um it is like you
said it's hypothetical um
it's just basically an indication that
um
you see it huh you see what I'm saying?
No, no. I'm I'm trying to just I'm
trying to
So Allah is telling Muhammad if
Okay.
I think the I think the word you're
probably looking but someone's used
today and yesterday is continuity.
No, not not necessarily continuity
because Yeah. Yeah. It it's it's
assuming that it's it's a continuity.
However, the part that makes it the
authority is the part where it says if
you doubt if you doubt what's been
revealed to you then do this. Go check
this. Yeah. If you doubt if you doubt
Moses did such and such a thing, then
the Jews who become Muslims will tell
you that he did that thing, right? And
they'll be using their scriptures to
give you the the substance of what
they're Well, they'll know of the story
from their scriptures. Exactly. So the
the the source of the authority of what
is like the the standard is the previous
scriptures. You get what I'm saying? So
if he sees that if he if he knows that
what he's what the story they heard of
Moses lines up with what they have in
the previous scripture, right? what
they're telling them, then he'll know
that the Quran is true and have no
reason to doubt. Well, no. What now
you're saying is if he See, now you've
thrown the hypothetical out. No, I'm I'm
working with the hypothetical. Yeah.
Yeah. It's a weird one. Go on and
continue. So, what's your argument?
Yeah. So, so basically the conclusion is
is that according to the hypothetical,
the previous scriptures are the
authority on whether or not the Quran
gets this stuff right or wrong.
Get what I'm saying? or whether this
thing happened or not which would then
mean whether the Quran if the thing
didn't happen.
So these things didn't happen then the
Quran would be false and Muhammad would
have good reason to doubt
potentially. Potentially. Yeah, that's
fair. That's a fair I think it's a fair
argument.
Thank you. Okay. Well, that that that's
all I wanted. I I just want to hear
Okay. Yeah. No, it it follows logically.
It follows logic. That's what
Oh my god. Logic.
[Music]